la justice la sphère liliane bettencourt
devrait bien donné lieu à un procès vous
le savez l'héritière de l'oréal femme la
plus riche d'europe âgé aujourd'hui de
86 ans a versé un milliard d'euros de
dons ces dernières années au photographe
françois-marie banier devenu l'un de ses
amis proches pour sa fille elle a été
d'une certaine manière abuser car elle
ne disposerait plus de toutes ses
facultés
ce que dément liliane bettencourt la
milliardaire et le photographe c'est le
dossier de cette édition il est signé
loïc de la mornais thierry breton il
n'existe que de très rares photos d'elle
encore moins d'imagés encore moins des
interviews liliane bettencourt est une
femme très discrète alors le combat se
déroule à pas feutrés mais il est
violent et l'enjeu colossal héritière du
groupe l'oréal liliane bettencourt est à
la tête d'une fortune estimée à 10
milliards d'euros
même si ses gains ont un peu fondu cette
année elle reste la 21e fortune mondiale
la troisième de france et demeure la
plus riche femme d'europe depuis une
vingtaine d'années l'héritière avait
noué une relation amicale avec cet homme
françois-marie banier peintre et
photographe il réalise notamment des
campagnes de publicité comme ici pour
une grande maison de couture au fil des
ans le photographe aurait reçu de
nombreux chèques des cadeaux de la part
de sa richissime amis au total des dons
d'environ un milliard d'euros
c'est en tout cas l'avis de la fille de
liliane bettencourt françoise ici en
écharpe bleue déjà héritière des parts
du groupe
elle est persuadée que sa mère s'est
fait abuser et a porté plainte contre le
photographe savez certains chèques
certains dons sont 250 millions vous
arriver vite à 500 millions ou 1
milliard quand il y à des tableaux aussi
réputés que des jericho ou des tableaux
de ce genre là des matisse on va très
vite des sommes très importantes
je pose alors la question de savoir si
donné un milliard d'euros un homme qui
n'est rien ce n'est pas en soi un acte
de faiblesse
en décembre dernier sortant
exceptionnellement de sa réserve
liliane bettencourt a accordé une
interview au journal du dimanche
indiquant je n'ai plus envie de voir ma
fille il faudrait tout de même que ma
fille se rende compte que je suis une
femme libre
le journaliste qui l'a interviewé assure
l'avoir trouvée saine d'esprit c'est
quelqu'un d'assez timide d'assez discret
et le fait qu'on puisse la présenté
publiquement comme une personne un peu
diminué ou une personne sous influence
c'est quelque chose qui semble-t-il la
blesse profondément trouvant que la
justice s'éternise
la fille bettencourt a adressé une
citation directe à comparaître au
photographe pour abus de faiblesse une
procédure coûteuse que ne peut pas
s'offrir tout le monde mais qui accélère
la tenue d'un procès si la fille
bettencourt est inquiète ce n'est pas
que pour le don d'un milliard d'euros sa
mère possède encore en effet 1% des
actions du groupe l'oréal en pleine
propriété
6e 1% revenait par exemple en cadeau aux
photographes la famille bettencourt ne
serait alors plus majoritaire dans le
groupe
son actionnaire majoritaire deviendrai
nestlé déjà propriétaire de 30% de
l'oréal
bien au delà d'une rivalité familiale se
cache donc un enjeu industriel
considérable